this is a tweet that came out the
following day all right i'm ready for
the tweet let's open it
oh he pooped hey guys welcome to another
episode of the wednesday checkup
today we're going to be talking about
markiplier's recent plight with the
medical system he had some abdominal
stuff going on which has been troubling
him for about half a decade but in order
to do this
i had to bring in a sub sub sub
specialist
welcome to the channel dr austin chang
what's going on buddy hey mike
thank you so much for having me my sub
specialty is actually in
gastroenterology which is
digestive diseases but then within that
i'm also an advanced endoscopist where i
do more complex procedures
you are also a tick-tock specialist
[Music]
hey guys uh thank you guys so much for
caring about
what's going on right now i just wanted
to give you a small update
yesterday i did have to get surgery done
i have what's called a small
bowel obstruction or i had it was formed
by
scar tissue from my previous surgeries
that i had
before i started youtube do you want to
talk about this
nasogastric tube he has in yeah as you
can imagine if there's a blockage in the
bowel
there's no place for food or liquids to
pass through and even if somebody isn't
eating anything by mouth the stomach for
instance is naturally secreting
a lot of fluid and even if you think
about our mouths and the saliva that we
make that we're constantly swallowing
that has no place to go this tube serves
to
suction out that liquid so that it
actually has a place to go
and it doesn't just build up what he
sounded like he was saying was that he
was having the small bowel obstruction
to translate into common english terms
is his small intestine which comes right
off of the stomach
had an obstruction he explained that it
was from his prior surgery there was
probably some scar tissue
that essentially closed off the
intestine preventing food
and the liquids from traveling down and
as a result you start
vomiting profusely you feel awful your
stomach starts expanding you're bloating
you're uncomfortable no matter what
medicine you give to a patient
unless you either open up the blockage
or
take all the the contents of the stomach
and the gi system out of the body
you're not going to stop vomiting so
putting in these ng tubes in patients
like this was
the number one way to relieve the
symptoms
and to buy time in order to get them to
the procedure hey guys
i'm at the hospital right now
i'm fine i've got an ng tube in my nose
right now which drains stuff out of my
stomach because i have a
small intestine blockage man
this is uh unexpected came out of
nowhere but i'm fine
it's nothing life threatening i don't
even think i'm gonna need surgery this
time
they're just gonna suck it out of me and
hopefully that fixes the problem
in five years two small bowel
obstructions
is that common uh do you i mean i know
there are recurrences especially once
you've had
an intestinal obstruction before and
surgery and adhesions but in his age is
that
have you seen patients like this is it
often you know i've seen patients like
this but
there's no predicting when a bowel
obstruction can happen again
after it's happened once if it's due to
the scar tissue that we were talking
about
yeah it sounds like he might not need
surgery this time around so i don't
exactly know if it's the same
cause of the obstruction again i wonder
if there's something else going on
like maybe something we call an ileus
where the intestines just slow to move
and in that case it just needs time to
kind of get going again
and we don't want to you know add more
food or liquid to it
and it will sort of we have to figure
out why that at least is happening but
you know
a little bowel rest might help this is
cool for the audience to know right
they're probably wondering if he can't
eat he can't drink how is he supposed to
stay hydrated how is he supposed to get
calories
you want to take us through uh the ways
that we can do that the main way we do
that really is through the iv
through a vein we're able to provide
fluids that way
we're able to sometimes even provide
nutrition some people
have issues that prevent them from being
able to eat for months on end
and sometimes people have to be on iv
nutrition
for a long time i've got good news uh
the ng tube has been taken
out of my nose and my gut because that's
what it does we did a bunch of tests
this morning
a lot of x-rays and a lot of scans and
some contrast to see if things were
moving through me
and it seemed like things were moving
through okay
which is good so the doc said we're
gonna take it out and
observe a little longer i'm still not
allowed to eat anything but
the doc said that if i can have a bowel
movement then everything is on the up
and up
we're waiting for the bowel movement
we're waiting for the flatulence
it's funny because literally as a med
student and as a resident early on
you're documenting like
no flatulence as of yet like you're
waiting for that moment what's
interesting to me is he mentioned the
contrast that they're doing i guess like
swallow studies or
is that something you usually do with
sbos yeah i think that if we're
suspecting that it's gonna clear up on
its own then we can get an
x-ray and have them drink contrast and
that contrast will basically be traced
through then tested and make sure it's
getting past
the point of blockage this was a tweet
that came out the following day all
right i'm ready for the tweet let's open
it
oh he pooped
actually i think i saw this trending
didn't this trend on twitter hashtag he
pooped
hashtag he poop isn't it funny to
celebrate about movement like people
don't think that that happens but
doctors celebrate poops what do we got
six sam tweets inspired some memes
okay we got some memes congratulations
this certificate is to commend
mark edward fischbach for
passing a bowel movement awarded the 3rd
of december signed
everyone this is a certificate of poop
you never thought that would come into
the conversation i wasn't sure if i was
supposed to come in anyway
because i didn't know if it was going to
be a problem but they said they were
glad i did
and this is how i know the bowel
obstructions are extra dangerous is
because they said if i waited
that's usually how people die from bowel
obstructions i wasn't in any danger of
dying because i came in way early
it's usually people that have these
kinds of pain for bowel obstructions and
they wait like a day or two days
just to go in like if you've got some
weird stomach pain
go see a doctor like it's it's it's
probably nothing
but it could also be your intestines
exploding okay
i don't want people to think if their
stomach hurts for a few hours their
intestines may explode
that's why i think it's so important to
have a primary care doctor because if
you have an established relationship
with a doctor
outside of an emergency setting then you
can contact that doctor and say
you know is this okay you know is it
okay to not run to the emergency room
right away
that's exactly what i would say that
basically it's that triage component
that people
don't appreciate uh as much because they
don't think about it it's natural not to
think about it but
we have like a 24-hour answering service
like most offices
do that i tell my patients like look if
this continues into tonight or gets
worse randomly in the middle of the
night you're not sure of what to do
call our number we'll have a resident
who's on call give you a call back
they'll help triage of whether you can
wait until an urgent care appointment in
the morning or
do you have to go to the er now because
we can talk through the symptoms we can
talk through
uh your history you know in his case
knowing that he has a history of small
bowel obstructions
it is wise to come in earlier than later
but maybe in someone who
you know ate some food and is having
some diarrhea and some nausea for
you know four hours maybe they don't
need to rush to the er
especially if they have access to a good
primary care doctor the first time that
it went down or the nurse tried to get
it down
it went into my lungs
[Laughter]
let me tell you getting a lube
covered plastic tube shoved into your
lungs ain't
fun at all and and it was i i felt so
bad for
for the nurse like i felt bad for the
nurse like
you know she shoves it down to my throat
and i'm just like she pulled it out a
little bit
not all the way so it's like still in my
nose and i'm like
i think that was in my lungs and she's
going like
no way that was in your lungs and i'm
like listen lady i
i'm not going to sue you or anything
like i'm just telling you i'm not an
expert at the inside of my lungs or how
that feels but that went in my lungs
oh my god stat portable chest x-ray
please
you know if he's coughing and he's not
able to tolerate the food placement
it could have gone down the wrong pipe
after you reach the back of your throat
it splits into your esophagus and then
the windpipe so
there is a possibility that the two may
have you know at least temporarily gone
down the wrong turn well that's why
right like one of the parts of placing
an ng tube is then listening
for the stomach for the the lungs and
making sure you don't hear
it in the lungs and you hear it properly
in the abdomen
maybe putting a little bulb on there and
squeezing some air in but if he's
already like can't
and is struggling to breathe i feel like
that's a good enough sign for me
clinically to know that i'm
not doing the right thing you know it
was so weird having the internet
celebrate
me having a bowel movement i can't
believe it's like i was
i knew it was going to be kind of like
that but i had no idea it was like you
guys were going to make a trend on
twitter or something like that
we are officially markiplier fans here
shout out mark we're glad you're doing
well
um if you ever want to do a try not to
laugh medical challenge with us we're
game dr
chang thank you so much for joining us
all of dr chang's information is going
to be linked down below
check out all of his social channels
he's an absolute rock star
accurate info he deals it not only in
the hospital side of medicine
but also the social media side of
medicine what goes into that
training other doctors truly amazing
work and if you want to see another
great video
check out my video here on the harsh
reality of being 800 plus pounds
actually the gentleman in this video is
the pinned comment click here and as
always stay happy and healthy
you